c'est une épreuve pour nous tous mais
noël arrive et nous devons le fêter
comme il se doit
je ne veux rien fait et je voudrais que
mossoul
la mère a été la plus grande aventure
risque que j'aie jamais connue sais tu
ce qu'elle répondait lorsqu'on lui
demandait quel était ce plus belles
créations
toi aussi
cette amère qui a créé notre monde ma
mère a inventé tout ça
elle était notre reine à votre service
françaises clarifient l'avenir des
quatre royaumes ne dépend que de toi
soit très prudente je vous attends des
machettes
[Musique]
mr gingembre veut gouverner tous les
royaumes
la rangée sert pouvez vous m'aider il
est temps de sauver le royaume
qu'elle va détruire tout ce que ma mère
a créé et tu prêtes
en mai